l'ukraine vie donc sa 19e journée de
guerre peu à peu les russes gagnent du
terrain y compris à kiev la capitale tôt
ce matin un immeuble d'habitation a été
frappé par un obus russe vous êtes sur
place johnatan walsh dans le quartier de
bologne c'est une scène de désolation
oui c'est assez impressionnant la scène
que vous pouvez voir derrière moi les la
destruction quasi quasi totale des
trois-quatre premiers étages de
l'immeuble que vous voyez le missile est
tombé à un missile est tombé à 5 heures
du matin sur sur cet immeuble ici
c'était là c'était la cage d'escalier et
vous voyez c'est complètement détruit
jusqu'au 3e ou 4e laitages et puis on
peut voir on peut voir les fenêtres et
les toutes les fenêtres complètement
soufflé toute la façade complètement
soufflé les balcons détruits qui qui qui
qui pendent certain qu'ils tiennent à
peine c'est vraiment une scène assez
impressionnante on imagine la terreur
vécue par les habitants de cet immeuble
nous avons parlé à une jeune femme
anastacia qui nous a raconté qu'ils nous
en raconter cette scène terrible quand
le quand le missile est tombé sur
l'immeuble la terre qui a tremblé et
toute sa famille heureusement a survécu
à l'explosion elle était située par
chance de l'autre côté de ceux de ce
bâtiment dont elle a réussi elle a
réussi à échapper au pire et puis elles
étaient en train de récupérer comme
d'autres habitants que nous avons vu
aujourd'hui ici ses effets personnels
les effets personnels de sa famille nous
avons rencontré beaucoup de ses
habitants qui sont évidemment vous
l'imaginez bien dans un état terrible
venir récupérer voilà on voit l'instant
un habitant sortir sortir là bas de
l'entrée qui est venu récupérer des
effets personnels dans un dans un carton
voilà donc vous l'avez dit vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure nous sommes dans le
dans le nord de kiev a hobo lawn dans le
centre ville de kiev qui est beaucoup
plus calme on peut parfois oublier la
guerre quelques quelques instants mais
je peux vous dire qu'ici dans le nord de
kiev c'est assez impressionnant le sont
des tirs d'artillerie qu'on entend en
permanence on a entendu tout à l'heure
également des tirs de la défense anti
aérienne a priori c'est ce que nous ont
dit les policiers 2
voilà raisonnée résonner dans le ciel
donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment assez
voilà leçons de la guerre ici est assez
impressionnant
merci beaucoup de natal volts pour ce
direct très concret et très parlant donc